ciao a tutti sono alberto cody e mi
occupo di comunicazione all'interno
della cooperativa sociale solidarietà ai
servizi e voi direte comunicazione in
una cooperativa sociale
cosa fa racconta storie come quella che
cercheremo di ascoltare oggi
ma facciamo un passo alla volta sono i
da rete servizi è nata nel 1979 a busto
arsizio a quattro aree di attività
l'area disabili che si occupa di servizi
per persone svantaggiate disabili o
fragili
l'area minori che si occupa di servizi
educativi scolastici di spazi bimbi nei
centri commerciali ed i centri estivi
l'area socio sanitaria che si occupa di
servizi socio sanitari e della gestione
di due poliambulatori riabilitativi e
l'area lavoro che si occupa di servizi
di inserimento lavorativo per persone
disabili o fragili
la cooperativa opera in sette regioni 24
province 85 comuni a 1.400 dipendenti e
quotidianamente si prende cura di 24.000
persone 24 mila persone che sono 24mila
storie che documentano una modalità di
lavoro della cooperativa allinsegna del
suo play off
mai più soli insieme ci riusciamo e oggi
la storia che vogliamo raccontarvi è
quella di tatiana perché esemplificativa
di un metodo di lavoro che parte dal
bisogno l'esigenza della persona e
coinvolge tutti gli interlocutori
possibili con al centro una persona sola
tatiana le strade di tatiana e dalla
cooperativa s'incrociano nel 2040 tiana
a 15 anni con una serie difficoltà
cognitive ed emotive legate alla sua
vita passata incontra solidariet e
servizi con una meta ben precisa quella
di un percorso verso una maggiore
autonomia come la cooperativa accetta
questa sfida per farlo vi racconto come
dal 2000 ad oggi si svolgono
quotidianamente le giornate di tatiana
dal 2000 al 2007
tatiana vive all'interno della comunità
socio sanitaria divergono insieme ad
altre persone in questa casa
l'assistenza degli operatori e 24 ore su
aiutano le persone nell'espletamento dei
bisogni primari nell'assunzione dei
farmaci ma differentemente da quello che
potrebbe essere un ospizio le persone
hanno dei compiti seppur minimi guidati
ma dei compiti come ad esempio possono
aiutare nell'appartamento della tavola
nello spazzare la casa
curiosa la figura ad esempio di giuseppe
il quale come molti di noi al vizio del
fumo quotidianamente consegna
all'educatrice un pacchetto di sigarette
e con l'educatrice si pianifica ogni
quanto giuseppe potrà fumare una
sigaretta poi le educatrici di ogni dice
ogni quattro ore
giuseppe ogni mezz'ora va a chiedere una
sigaretta per ora l'obiettivo è quello
che anche giuseppe capisca che forse una
sigaretta ogni mezz'ora non è il massimo
per lui
tutte le mattine queste persone si
svegliano in casa loro
arriva il pulmino della cooperativa che
li preleva e li porta appresso i servizi
di riferimento servizi diurni tatiana
dal 2000 al 2007 frequenta il centro
diurno disabili di marnate dove insieme
ad altre persone dalle 9 alle 16
fa attività di natura ludica di natura
laboratoriale laboratorio di pittura
guidati dagli educatori nel percorso per
le autonomie italiana un passo decisivo
sia nel 2007 quando viene spostata al
centro socio educativo di busto arsizio
dove tatiana continua a fare attività di
carattere ludico laboratoriale per cui
appunto laboratori di scrittura
piuttosto che attività di cineforum
frequente attività di hobby come quella
di tutti noi vanno in palestra cene qua
dietro una va in piscina e inizia a fare
una serie di attività che possano
permettere di sviluppare alcune
autonomie viene educata all'utilizzo dei
soldi può andare a comprare i giornali
tutte le mattine da sola a utilizzare i
mezzi pubblici e inizia degli
inserimenti di tirocini lavorativi
all'interno delle aree di attività della
cooperativa dove nei settori più
interessanti per lei principalmente il
make up interessante vedere come il
lavoro che viene svolto da tatiana con
l'educatrice cresce la pianificazione
della sua settimana avviene
tatiana e l'educatrice assieme decidono
le attività che in quella settimana
possono essere migliori
l'obiettivo quale è quello che tatiana
possa essere pronta per affrontare il
mondo nel 2009
tatiana si trasferisce presso la
residenza is a tanzi di cassano magnago
una casa vissuta appieno dai le sue
pedale persone che vivono dentro 12
persone sei uomini e sei donne
l'educatore ha un ruolo minimale si
presenta a cena gli ospiti hanno questo
compito
chi si occupa di fare la spesa a chi di
cucinare chi di lavorare a casa chi di
lavare nei weekend invitano i familiari
a pranzo o vanno a pranzo dai familiari
vanno a giocare a pallone vanno a fare
gite prendono i mezzi autonomamente
vanno le loro attività lavorative
crescerà autonomia di queste persone
cresce tatiana e cresce anche il suo
amore per le persone per le persone che
ha intorno e si rende sempre qui
disponibili disponibile alle attività
della casa
nel frattempo tatiana tutte le mattine
prende l'autobus e va al centro socio
educativo della cooperativa alla fine
del 2016
tatiana documenta ai suoi educatori di
riferimento il desiderio di avere una
casa tutta sua e a febbraio del 2017 via
inaugurata la casa per le autonomie casa
lab
a fagnano loro bergoro per l'esattezza
dove tatiana vive assieme a laura
un'altra ospite qui l'educatore è come
un amico che viene a trovarti a cena
perché le autonomie è tutto delle
ragazze è un servizio di natura
residenziale e sperimentale perché
sperimentale perché grazie al lavoro
svolto dalla hit i manager della
cooperativa andrea civati e da una
società esterna si è potuto adottare la
casa di tecnologia domotica tecnologia
domotica che però vuole essere a
supporto delle attività delle ragazze
non controllo in stile grande fratello
ma vuole essere un internet of things
and were hubble things che si ha a
disposizione delle ragazze a noi ci
piace definirlo in modalità educativa
per spiegarlo faccio alcuni esempi
tatiana è una che ha molto a cuore la
sua alimentazione una sana
alimentazione come molti di noi ma
escluso evidentemente tutte le sue
domeniche sere si mette sul divano con
l'ipad e inizia attraverso un software a
pianificare la sua dieta settimanale
questo software permette di riconoscere
attraverso delle icone i differenti cili
tatiana registra in memoria il suo peso
e le chilocalorie che dovrà prendere
durante la settimana e inizia a
pianificare la sua dieta quindi
probabilmente come molti di noi
tatiana magari segnalerà che per due
sere di fila settimana o è la pizza
evidentemente software attraverso i
programmi del segnalerà che non è la
cosa più indicata però in tal modo potrà
vedere come la giusta combinazione di
vitamine e carboidrati grassi e proteine
possono essere combinati per
un'alimentazione sana e perfetta come vi
dicevo tatiana e una che ha molto a
cuore la cucina è quindi un sabato sera
decide di invitare una serie di amici e
l'educatrice chiede a laura mentre lei
si mette a mettere a posto la casa di
andare a fare la spesa
laura da fare la spesa sulla via del
ritorno per un imprevisto cambia il
percorso abituale e non si ritrova con i
riferimenti visivi cosa succede
entrambe le ragazze sono dotate di uno
smartwatch con sensore di
geolocalizzazione che ha salvato i
percorsi preferiti percorsi preferiti
che sono usualmente casa lavoro casa
servizi oppure altri servizi preferiti
come sono andare ad esempio a far la
spesa
cosa succederà solo smartwatch che laura
avrà si accenderà una spia rossa che le
segnala di essere non sul percorso
abituale di conseguenza laura ha due
possibilità
1 provare da sola a rientrare sul
percorso preferito alternativamente
schiacciando un bottone presente su
smartwatch si accenderà una spia di
colore verde che manderà un alert
tramite il servizio telegram sullo
smartphone dell'educatrice che segnalerà
uno che laura fuori percorso due geo
localizzare la posizione
altro esempio tutti gli atri domestici
della casa sono dotati di sensori con
l'obiettivo appunto di un monitoraggio
per vedere banalmente quando il
frigorifero viene aperto con che
frequenza se viene aperto per caso di
notte l'obiettivo è appunto
quello di rielaborare i dati assieme le
ragazze per poterli analizzare in
funzione di un miglioramento e maggiore
consapevolezza dei propri atteggiamenti
da ultimo si è stata dotata la casa di
un dispositivo che permette di aiutare
le ragazze ad essere autonome anche
sull'assunzione dei farmaci che se
ricordiamo nei due set precedenti erano
entrambi guidati dagli educatori in che
modo in memoria del dispositivo
ci sono la dose esatta è il tempo in cui
le ragazze possono prelevare i farmaci
attraverso un dispositivo di
riconoscimento facciale verrà appunto
dotate sia tatiana che laura della
giusta dose nella determinata ora di
riferimento l'obiettivo è quello che le
ragazze possano anche rischiare di più
essere consapevoli di atteggiamenti
usuali inusuali e della capacità di
poter lavorando assieme l'educatore
migliorarli tutte le mattine quindi
tatiana e laura si svegliano fanno
colazione e vanno ai servizi della
cooperativa tatiana al centro socio
educativo mentre laura va a lavorare
presso una delle attività dell'area
lavoro se vi ricordate
tutto questo è un percorso per una
maggiore autonomia maggiore autonomia
che vuole arrivare a un indipendenza
anche economica e quando parlo di
indipendenza economica parlo esattamente
di questo l'esperienza di solidarietà e
servizi nell'inserimento lavorativo ha
origine nel 95 quando stefano un ragazzo
ospite di uno dei centri diurni esprime
un desiderio poter avere un lavoro vero
provocati dal sogno di stefano e grazie
all'aiuto di amici imprenditori e
manager
siamo riusciti a realizzare un progetto
ambizioso offrire opportunità di lavoro
ovvero a persone fragili o disabili
[Musica]
mi occupo della gestione documentale
principalmente per quanto riguarda la
scansione dei documenti
lavorare qui è una cosa fondamentale
perché è la cooperativa è una famiglia
si chiama fabrizio lavoro nell'area
documentale e mi occupo della
normalizzazione dell'astensione dei
documenti destro operativo ha trovato un
ambiente molto familiare oltre al fatto
di avere imparato molte cose fatto nuova
e differente lavorativa di procedure che
non conoscevo all'inizio proprio per la
tipologia di persone inserite
ci siamo concentrati su lavorazioni
semplici e ripetitive come gli
assemblaggi o scandite da tempi precisi
e ordinati come le lavorazioni
meccaniche da lì volendo dar risposta ai
crescenti bisogni delle persone
incontrate e al tempo stesso
differenziare l'offerta ai nostri
clienti abbiamo introdotto tecnologia
all'avanguardia nelle lavorazioni
meccaniche creato un centro servizi per
la gestione documentale un centro di
regenesi e assemblaggio di apparati tlc
e sviluppato servizi nell'ambito del
business process outsourcing siamo
barbana o quasi 44 anni e mi occupo
delle note spese dei dipendenti interni
esterni del cliente
abbiamo la possibilità di sentirsi utili
quindi ho la possibilità di sentirmi
utile e di svolgere un lavoro che ha una
sua parte l'importanza e mi dà la
possibilità di vivere una vita che può
essere considerata sotto un certo punto
di vista normale
avere un lavoro vero significa
uguaglianza uguaglianza perché io non mi
sento discriminata
è un lavoro che mi fa sentire uguale a
tutti gli altri mi sento valorizzata e
per me questo è importantissimo
mi sento non un peso ma un valore
aggiunto
[Musica]
man mano ea dispetto di tutti i luoghi
comuni
le attività sono divenute sempre più
complesse e ad alto valore aggiunto
permettendo così anche a persone con
fragilità psicologiche o sociali di
arrivare a dare tantissimo in termini di
performance aziendali grazie ad un
contesto particolarmente attento ai loro
bisogni
[Musica]
oggi le persone impiegate stabilmente
nell'area lavoro sono diventate 65 e
solidarietà e servizi negli anni ha
acquisito clienti importanti che
trovando i nuovi fornitori professionali
affidabili e precisi al giusto posto
continuano a darci fiducia e ci aiutano
a crescere
una boccata d'aria rispetto agli altri
lavori che ho fatto negli ultimi nove
anni e che ora starebbero file word
però io con gli inglesi una premessa un
genere centralini comandano su 4 da 46
compiuti in contemporanea
questo qui per me è un ulteriore passo
in più che ho fatto in cooperativa da
quando sono arrivato
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la storia di tatiana esemplifica bene
quello che è il metodo di lavoro della
cooperativa che partendo dal mai più
soli
cerca di coinvolgere tutti anche voi
perché il percorso che cerchiamo di fare
è un'avventura un percorso di vita che
possa tener conto di tutti gli
interlocutori che aiutino le persone a
partire dal loro bisogno dalla loro
esigenza persone che nonostante la
diversità si sentano utili e possano
vivere una dieta piena da parte mia e di
andrea un ringraziamento principale
trovarci presto e anche la parte loro